[MUSIC PLAYING]
DARYUSH LAQAB: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us.
My name is Daryush.
I'm the product manager for
Google's Contact Center AI.
It's nice to have you all here.
We have a jam-packed
agenda for you.
I'm going to start
by telling you
a little bit about what
is Contact Center AI
and what is it good for,
but most of the session
will be presented
by our partners.
Right after me, Josh will take
the stage and Josh is Mitel.
And he will show you
how Mitel has integrated
into the entire Google
Contact Center AI stack
and how they have used
that to build a more
intelligent contact center.
After Josh, we will
hear from Ofer.
Ofer is the general
manager for Chatbase.
Chatbase is an Area 120
project within Google.
Ofer is going to talk about
how Chatbase, complemented
by Contact Center AI, can
help you find call drivers,
call topics, and call intents
in your Contact Center logs.
Traci will take this
stage after that,
and Traci is going to tell you
about how KPMG's Intelligent
Interactions platform works
with Contact Center AI
to optimize your contact
center operations.
And Andrea from Genesys
will wrap things up
by showing a new/alternate way
of thinking about customer care
channels.
So with that, let's
talk a little bit
about Contact Center AI.
Contact Center AI is part
of a larger effort at Google
called Cloud AI.
In Cloud AI, we categorize our
efforts into three categories.
Category number one is our
platform-- our AI platform,
which enables machine learning
engineers and data scientists
to run their machine learning,
training, prediction,
and analytics jobs, either in
the cloud using Cloud Machine
Learning Engine or in a hybrid
or even on-prem environment
using Kubeflow.
The second category is
our pre-trained machine
learning models, easily
consumable through APIs
like our image recognition,
object recognition models,
translations model, and
natural language model.
If you bring in your
own labeled data,
you can then customize these
pre-trained APIs for you,
for your use cases using
our AutoML technology.
And I'm sure you have all
seen a bunch of announcements
around AutoML
yesterday and today.
The third category
is our AI solutions.
In the solutions category,
we get these pre-trained APIs
built new--
pre-trained models and APIs--
package them together
in a contained solution
focused on a set of
very specific use cases.
And Contact Center AI is one
of those solutions focused
on customer care and
contact center use cases.
But how did we get there?
We talked to a whole bunch of
customers and a lot of partners
and they told us a
lot of pain points.
These pain points boil into
three distinct categories.
Category number one is the
infamous long and deep IVR
tree.
Press one to go left.
Press two to go sharp right.
Press three to go
slightly right.
And I bet you, none
of you actually
enjoys that experience.
If you do, please do
not raise your hand,
but anyone that I've talked to
doesn't enjoy that experience.
But once you actually
push two about seven times
and three about six
times and along the way
you provide your account
number a couple times
and you finally get
to a live agent,
that agent turns around
and promptly asks
you, what is your
account number?
This information that you
provide the IVR at times gets
missed when the IVR transitions
the call to a live agent.
Now that you have provided your
account number for the third--
or n-th time for that matter--
the agent promptly
puts you on hold,
lets you listen to some music
while the agent on the side
is frantically searching for
the answer to your question.
This makes it for a very
poor caller experience.
I don't think any of us
enjoys that experience.
But it also makes it very,
very expensive to operate
the contact center.
When we talk to our
customers, to our partners,
we figured out that at
some points in time,
it takes up to about $15 to
answer a call that actually
comes to a contact center.
That's a lot of
money for one call.
Also, the agents
are being pushed.
They need to find
these answers quickly.
Their desktop is a mess.
They have CRM.
They have Contact Center.
They have Search.
That results into roughly,
about one out of three agents
churning within 12 months
of joining a contact center.
Makes it very, very expensive
to operate a contact center.
So this is why we thought,
how can we actually utilize
AI to make this experience
better, both for the caller
and for the agent?
And that's why we built
Contact Center AI.
Contact Center AI has three
major components in it.
The first one is virtual agent.
It is based on our Dialogflow
Enterprise product.
In addition to automating
the common transactional
and informational
calls, Dialogflow
allows you to
flatten the IVR tree.
It allows you to replace press
one for x, press two for y
with hello, I'm an
automated agent.
How can I help you today?
And it can continue
that conversation
with the caller in a natural
language kind of a way.
It also has the ability
to raise the call directly
to a human agent.
And it will make sure that
all the context gathered
during the call is actually
passed from the automated agent
to the live agent, which
results of the second bucket--
Agent Assist.
We built Agent
Assist to make sure
that the experience
for the live agents
gets better and
more streamlined.
Agent Assist-- as
its name implies--
will assist the agent
by monitoring the call,
building the context around that
conversation between that agent
and that customer.
Will go to the knowledge
base, fetches the right answer
or the right article
that has the answer in it
and surfaces it to the agent.
So hopefully, you
will never again
be put on hold by
an agent, hopefully.
The third piece is
conversational topic modeling.
Conversational
topic modeling would
allow you to discover topics in
your chat logs and audio logs.
Not only will it tell you
what topics your customers
were calling you
about, it will tell you
which key words they used
to articulate that topic.
What were the top sentences they
used to talk about that topic?
I'm not going to talk
about topic modeling
that much right now because
you will hear a lot about it
from our partners.
By the way, whatever
I've mentioned so far
and I used the term caller, it
works both for audio and phone,
as well as text and chat.
We will manage the session
between the contact center
deployment and all the
AIs behind the scenes.
Everything is backed
by a knowledge base.
You can create multiple
knowledge bases
to back your Agent Assist,
as well as virtual agent.
By the way, in this color-coded
slide, Google builds the red.
Partner or the customer
builds the green.
That's what the colors mean.
I'm not going to
spend too much time
going through the architecture
right now due to time,
but if you are interested
in learning more
about the technical aspects of
it, see me after the session
or see us at the booth.
Trust me, we love to
geek out on this stuff.
We'd love to tell you about it.
Same thing with the
topic modeling-- see us
and then we'll chat about that.
Contact Center AI is
available in alpha
exclusively through
our partners today,
including our SI partners.
They are all fairly
familiar with our stack
and can actually help
you on board onto it.
Before I turn it over
to Josh to tell us
about the goodness of
Mitel's contact center,
let me make a shameless plug
for another session on CCAI
that we have tomorrow
in this room at 11:40.
We will see a lot more
demos about integrations
into Contact Center AI.
We will see some
today, but tomorrow, we
will see a lot
more integrations.
Maybe even couple of
people calling one
another in the same room.
So if you want to
hear audio feedback,
tomorrow is the best day.
We also have sessions on
speech-to-text and Dialogflow
Enterprise, which I think
they have occurred already
so once you actually got
your hands on the videos,
I encourage you
to check that out.
And please, please, please
go to cloud.google.com
/solutions/contact-center
and obviously,
I got the font size wrong.
Please do not put
that on the feedback.
But please, go there.
You will read a lot about
Contact Center's moving parts.
But the most important part is
at the bottom of the screen.
You need to scroll
all of a down,
there is a blue button
that says I'm Interested.
Click on it, fill
out that form, I
would love to chat
with you about it.
With that, I turn
it over to Josh.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSHUA HASLETT: Well,
thank you Daryush.
I can't say how excited
we are to be here today,
working with Google to
really transform the customer
experience and deliver
something new, something
we call the intelligent
customer experience.
Mitel's been in
business for 45 years
and our focus is delivering
seamless communications
and collaboration and
really helping businesses
communicate more effectively.
We have over 70 million
end users of our technology
around the world
and we're number two
in Contact Center for total
contact centers deployed
globally, with more
than 25,000 businesses
and trusting their customer
experience to Mitel Solutions.
Our expectations
are changing and I'm
sure you're aware of this
just as much as I am.
Most of us want to
self-serve today.
We want to be able to do through
our app or on the website,
find the information
we're looking for,
transact the way we
want to transact,
and we want that to be
able to work on our time,
on our schedule,
and from our device.
And as a matter
of fact, Synthetix
has identified that 90% of us
will go to a company's website
before we'll call that company.
So to me, that means anytime
we're calling a company,
it's an exception.
It's a missed opportunity for
a good customer experience.
And how important is
customer experience anyway?
Well, Walker has identified that
by 2020, customer experience
will be more important
than product or price.
So it's key that
we figure out how
to re-innovate and digitally
transform our businesses.
Let's take Tesla, for instance.
They've completely disrupted
the auto ownership experience.
And we know them all
for electric vehicles,
but did you know that they
can do over-the-air updates?
Push things like ludicrous
speed or autopilot
after you've rolled the
car out of the dealership?
Secondly, they can
do remote diagnostics
and they can roll a mobile
technician to your site
to come do repairs and service.
I would say it's these things--
these long-tail
differentiators--
that will in the
end, be the brand
that people know about Tesla.
And they're way ahead
on the technology
from their competition.
That's why we're re-imagining
the customer experience,
to bring that intelligent
customer experience to all
the companies that use
Mitel Solutions because we
want them to be able to
transform their businesses,
as well.
So we're combining
Mitel's 45-year history
of understanding how
businesses communicate
both with omnichannel
contact center and the way
that we do complex routing
rules and combining
that with Google's
Contact Center Cloud AI.
The first is analytics.
So we do a lot of contact center
business and the key thing
that we typically do
is focus contact center
metrics internally.
We help the business understand
how efficient their agents are.
You heard Daryush
say how expensive it
is to run a contact center.
That's why the metrics
are focused on keeping
those agents efficient.
But I would say that with AI, we
need to start to look outward.
It's not so much more about how
do you run efficient agents,
it's about how do you take
those exceptions when people
are calling in
your contact center
and do something smart with it?
So the ability to
use topic modeler
allows us to take a look at
the information about why
your customers are calling and
help you improve your products
and solutions.
The second is virtual agent.
If we all want to
self-serve, then it
makes sense that an
always-on agent that
can get us the answers
that we're looking for
would be very helpful.
So with the virtual agent
capability from Google,
we're able to connect
the customer directly
to the knowledge base
inside the organization.
This allows us to help
that customer get answers
to their questions in
real-time, with the most
up-to-date information
that's available to them.
And then, of course, when
we go to a live agent,
we want to make sure
that the customer's
context of the conversation
with the virtual agent
is maintained.
So we're going to pass
that whole conversation
to the live agent, make sure
they understand the context,
and then we're going to keep
the AI in the conversation
to help coach and do research
for that agent in real-time.
Now the same way that Google is
democratizing AI and bringing
that to all of us
as enterprises,
Mitel wants to make
sure that we can
take the capabilities of the
Contact Center AI components
and bring them to all
verticals-- industries--
and make sure that all size
businesses can deploy this.
So we've integrated it directly
into our CloudLink platform.
It's a cloud-born, native
microservice architecture
that's global, that allows us to
securely connect to the contact
centers that our customers
run, either hosted
in cloud or in their
on-site deployments.
So let's talk about
analytics for a second.
We took a look at why our
customers are calling us.
So in the Mitel
sales support queue,
we ran more than
20,000 call records
through the topic modeler
engine and we took analysis
on what was coming in.
We identified when we
had a product launch,
we actually had a
migration licensing problem
and we found that
through the signal
here that you see on the
green line on the graph, that
shows that we had
upgrade in software
as a high component for
why people were calling in.
Now we were able to put
a migration fix in place
and you can see that
green line trend down
rather rapidly
after that was done.
This is how we were
able to improve
our experience for our
resellers and for our customers.
Now, we're working
with other companies
to make sure that we
validate this technology.
We want to make sure that
it's simple to deploy
and easy to on board.
So Acendas Vacations,
Acendas Travel
is helping us to work
through some of this.
And as a matter of
fact, Rodney Pattison
is here with us today--
the CTO of Acendas.
And the key things
that he's excited about
with using AI in
his business is how
to personalize the
interactions for his customers,
enhanced support--
extending his hours and making
that interaction better--
and then providing his
advisors with more effective
means to be very good in that
consultative vacation planning
that they do.
So without further ado,
let's go to a demo.
So I'm on Acendas'
vacation website here
and you'll notice that
there's many categories
on their website.
They've got great information--
advisors that are experts in
destination for this luxury
vacation travel, destinations
that I can choose from,
experiences.
They've even got
a really good blog
that's very rich with content.
The problem is as a
customer, I'm not really sure
where to start.
I'm not sure what
my vacation needs
to be so I want to
talk to an advisor that
can help me through this.
So on their website,
I see there's
a number of different
ways to contact them.
I can come in
through a voice call.
I can email them.
But in this case, I
want to do a live chat.
So I'm going to give them a
little of my information here.
And while this is
queuing up, I'm
able to look at a little of
the information on the website.
Make sure our
internet connection's
working smoothly here today.
So now I'm greeted by Marisol--
the Acendas travel bot.
And Marisol can help guide
me through my preferences,
experiences I'm looking for.
So in this case, I'm interested
in a family vacation.
And I think based
upon my kids' age,
they like to go
play at the beach
so maybe we'll go to Hawaii.
Now Marisol takes me through an
understanding of my preferences
and at that time,
it's looking at what
advisors in the back
end are available that
can help me with my
consultative vacation planning.
I think I'll just
relax this time.
So at this point,
Marisol is going
to give me to an agent that can
help me with this interaction.
Turns out, Ahmed's the right
person for me to talk to.
So just like I mentioned,
we passed the entire script
of the bot interaction with the
customer right to the agent.
So as Ahmed, I can get the
understanding of the customers
context--
where they want to go,
who the customer is--
and at this point,
I can say, I'll
help you with your
Hawaiian vacation travels.
If I could type.
So that we're staying in
stream right back and forth
with the customer, same
in the bot interaction.
And now we'll see
suggestions coming in.
So I mentioned the AI
stays in the conversation
and we start feeding the
agent real information that's
pertinent to that conversation.
So the first article
that comes up here
is Hawaiian Islands Travel
for Families, which is
exactly what I had asked for.
So now I can take a look at
some of the Acendas travel
information.
I can see that Maui is a
good place for families
that want to relax.
Oahu's a good place for the
classic Hawaii experience.
I think Maui sounds good.
Now at the same
time, as an agent,
I can pass this information
right to the customer
so that they can
look for themselves
about that information and
they can be guided, as well.
So I'm going to go ahead
and end this interaction
and we're going to go
into a voice interaction.
MARISOL: Hello, thank you for
calling Acendas Vacations.
I'm Marisol, the
Acendas travel bot.
Please tell me what type of
vacation you are looking for.
JOSHUA HASLETT: I
want to go to Europe.
MARISOL: Do you know where
you would like to go?
JOSHUA HASLETT: No, but I'd
like to talk to somebody
that can give me some ideas.
MARISOL: No problem.
We have expert
advisors that can help
you find the perfect location.
Are you interested
in a guided tour?
JOSHUA HASLETT: No, thanks.
MARISOL: OK, we would
be delighted to help
you plan your vacation.
Please hold on while I pass you
to one of our expert advisors
who can help you plan
a fantastic trip.
JOSHUA HASLETT:
So at this point,
the call comes through to the
right agent that has expertise
on European vacation traveling.
And that agent is
handed a transcript
of the voice interaction
between the bot and the human.
And as we start getting
into this conversation,
we can actually expand
to provide suggestions
the same way that
we did in chat.
So Acendas vacations is excited
about this opportunity--
if we can go back to the
presentation monitor.
Thank you.
They're really
excited about being
able to focus on improving
matching accuracy for customers
as they come to their
website and want to find
that consultative vacation.
They're also wanting
to increase the success
rate of first-time bookings
and repeat bookings.
Come see more down at our
booth in Moscone West, 1323.
Thank you, and at point,
I'll turn it over to Ofer.
[APPLAUSE]
OFER RONEN: Hello.
How many people here, if they
could do a project in weeks,
would prefer that over months?
Just a show of hands.
And the rest of you maybe
didn't hear the question.
So Chatbase can
help with just that.
Teams are building
virtual agents
for contact centers can
now save a ton of time.
So we've heard about how
topic modeling can give you,
at a high level, what calls
and live chats are about.
Well, what we've
done is we've gone
and at a very specific
use case level,
are able to map out the
flows of those conversations.
All that is made possible by
leveraging Google's machine
learning that's been
developed over many years.
We're within Google.
And the same machine learning
also powers Google Search--
parts of Google Search
and Assistant and Gmail.
So I'm excited to
say that today, we're
announcing our
early access program
called Chatbase Enterprise
Edition, which does just that.
And if you step back--
for the last couple years,
we've been doing optimization
of virtual agents and we've done
that for hundreds of thousands
of virtual agents, processing
billions of messages
to virtual agents.
And the new part that
we're announcing today
is to help you with insights for
building these virtual agents.
So normally, when a
team wants to build
a virtual agent for
a contact center,
they get experts from within
the company into a room.
Sometimes, they
bring in consultants.
And they brainstorm,
what should we build?
They might brainstorm the flows
and they might think about,
how might people phrase this?
And they might come up with
maybe, 10, 20, 50 variations.
But if you use data, we've
seen that you can get thousands
of variations and
that makes your bots,
your virtual agents smart.
So really, there's
three shortcomings
to this brainstorm approach.
One is that you don't
predict all the nuances
of the conversation, all the
edge cases where conversation
might go.
Two is that you miss trends
in the contact center,
whether it's seasonality,
new products,
or other things like that.
It just is hard to
keep up with that.
And three-- third shortcoming is
that it's a slow process, very
slow to flesh out everything.
But really what
it's all about is
it's a black box what goes
on in the contact center.
What are people calling
about, how do they phrase
the question is
not always clear.
Sometimes, they even
say they don't even
know what their problem is.
They're trying to figure it out.
Whether good responses by
agents is also not always clear.
And so this is where
Chatbase comes in.
So we tag all the parts
of the conversation--
actually at the
highest level, we
tag what the
conversation's about.
This is a billing example.
Someone's calling to
change their bill due date.
And so we call it the driver.
The highest level is billing.
The intent level is change my
bill due date-- more specific.
And then we go beyond
that, you see the steps
in that conversation to what
date they want to change it to
and then, the customer
provides the new date.
So for each of these
nodes, we extract
thousands of variations.
For example, this is real data.
When someone
provides a new date,
you expect them to
just give a date.
But we've seen in the
data people say, how
about between the
3rd and the 5th?
Or mid-month on a Friday--
these are real examples.
Most virtual
agents, were like, I
don't know what
you want from me.
I wasn't trained for this.
But if you use the
data-driven approach,
it can really handle
all these cases.
So I'm going to talk
about the three steps
for building data-driven
virtual agents.
It starts with discovering
what's in your data.
And then you deploy
it to production.
And then in production, you
optimize the experiences.
And we're going to go
into each one of these.
So first step of
the discovery phase
is to find what are the
high-level drivers that people
are calling in about?
So we use unsupervised
machine learning, also known
as clustering, to
give you a sense
for what are the key themes.
And you can see here that
billing, and accounts,
and returns are major
drivers, but that tech support
and payment are not as common.
So let's go for a second
into the billing and flesh
that out because it
seems to be common.
So within billing, you see
we've clustered requests
for changing bill due date and
that's a pretty big cluster.
And then, requests for
charges on your bill
or discounts to your
bill are less common.
At this stage, we use some
supervised machine learning
to clean up the
grouping, but it's really
the unsupervised that gives
you a sense of where to look
and what's important.
Next step is to go deeper
into change bill due date
because it seems to be a large
intent within a large driver.
And so the next step
is to generate--
and this can be done
in a couple hours,
something we've heard takes
a week to four weeks--
you can generate
a detailed flow.
Once that intent is triggered--
change bill due date--
you can see all the ways
those conversations go.
So in this case,
a common flow is
to verify the name,
then what date,
and confirming the new date.
Each one of these
nodes, behind it
has the thousands of
ways that it was said.
And Google's one of
the few companies
that understand
language-- it's been
our business for a long time.
And so it's a good technology
to apply to this problem.
So now we have the building
blocks for the virtual agent
and we've looked at it.
We verified that that it looks
good and it's time to deploy.
And so you deploy it
to your virtual agent
so that's out there in the
wild being used by customers.
And then, you want to optimize.
There's always
going to be things
that you miss, different
things that didn't show up
in the original
data and so this is
where you have a chance
to use the Chatbase not
handled report.
It shows you all the cases
where the bot was like,
I don't know what the
customer is saying.
And here we, again,
use machine learning.
So in the case of, let's
say, my bill timing
won't work and
get paid on second
so we need a new due date--
those weren't caught.
But with supervised
machine learning,
we suggest the intent.
So we tell you this is what
we believe this should map to.
And with human review, you
can accept the whole thing.
If there's one that
you're not sure about,
you can bring up
the full transcript
to confirm the context of it
to make sure it's appropriate.
After you've gone
through this step,
the final step is
to check the funnel.
Are people getting through this
change bill due date funnel?
For a specific intent,
check the funnel.
You can see there's a drop off,
not everyone gets through it.
And here, again, you can
bring up sample transcripts
to see, why are
people dropping off?
And this is it could be a
customer experience issue
and that will come up
in the transcripts.
So one large enterprise that
we've done this analysis for
shared that, this way of
building virtual agents
is like moving at
200 miles per hour,
compared to their
existing way which
is 10 to 20 miles per hour.
So it's like going from
a horse and carriage
to a well-tuned race car.
Anyone that's interested
in learning more about this
can visit Chatbase
and request a demo.
You can also come by the Contact
Center AI booth, where I'll be.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Next, Traci will
come [INAUDIBLE]..
TRACI GUSHER: Thanks, Ofer.
So as Ofer said,
contact centers are
a bit of a black box
and the environment
that we're in today
that's just not acceptable
because our call centers have
regulatory pressures on them.
They cost us a ton of money.
And ultimately, they're the
channel to our customers.
And the reputational
risk that we
have if we're not doing
it right is just too big
not to be doing
something about it.
So KPMG has been working
with a lot of customers
to help them with their
contacts centers and the broader
customer experience process.
And while we've been doing
a lot of topic modeling,
we've been doing
it more by our data
scientists and our
engineers using more
customized, tailored approaches.
So when Google gave
us the opportunity
to test this new
topic modeling API,
we were thrilled because
we saw all the opportunity
in the world to take it to our
clients as a high accelerator
to the work that
we've been doing
and bring a great amount of
acceleration and efficiency
to some of the projects that
we could have done before
and that we will
do in the future.
Topic modeling really is--
as we look at it--
is the foundation of all
of the art of the possible
that you can do in
the contact center
with artificial intelligence.
And one of our lead
data scientists--
Dr. Arthur Franke--
compares data to farming.
So instead of data as the new
oil, data is the new soil.
And topic modeling, you can
think of as a key seed that
will help you grow
your AI, as you
move into more AI-enabled
contact centers.
So if we take a look at a more
end-to-end type of approach
and one that starts
with topic modeling
as its foundational element,
we look at topic modeling
to drive out the topics that
are telling us what is happening
in these contact centers.
What are people calling about?
What are the trends?
What are the spikes?
What is the seasonality?
And then we're applying
insight to them.
Because once you apply
business insight--
operational insight over
what's happening in the topic
modeling, you start
to learn more and more
not just about your
contact centers,
but about your
overall organization.
And those things drive
a lot in terms of value.
We divided into
these two buckets--
let's improve agents
and let's improve
our actual optimization.
The optimization that happens
from within the organization,
the impacts that come from
using artificial intelligence
in your contact centers.
So let's take a look quickly,
at what we're getting
from the topic modeling itself.
So at its root, we're
getting increased insights.
We're understanding the intents
and the compound intents
that occur in these calls or
in these chat logs in order
for us to really
understand, what
are the problems our
customers are experiencing?
Are we able to address
those problems?
And when we address those
problems, are they satisfied?
It also enables us to take
that business oversight,
overlay it, and understand
trends in the information.
So where are my spikes?
Where are my issues?
Were are my problems?
Where's abnormality--
there we go--
where's abnormality in what's
happening in my call centers?
And can I correct for it?
And on the benefit
side, there's really
a number of different things
that can drive out of this.
So one of the areas
is eradication.
There's nothing better
to improve a call center
than to eradicate the
conversation altogether.
If you understand that
your customers are having
a specific problem
that could be solved
by updating your website, by
pushing alerts or notifications
to them, by making it more
obvious or improved how they
can answer that question using
one of your mobile channels
and avoid the call or the chat
into your customer contact
center altogether--
that's the best outcome.
Your customer never
had a problem--
that's good customer
experience--
and the cost doesn't
exist anymore
because it's
already been solved.
And there's others, as well.
So you know, feeding
into agent training--
like Ofer talked
about-- in terms
of being able to build more
virtually-driven agents
and use the data to
enhance it, is imperative,
as well as a number
of other things.
So as I mentioned,
we were really
thrilled to be given
the opportunity
to get our hands dirty using
the topic modeling API.
And what we did was
we took 90,000 chat
logs from our own IT chat log,
from our own IT help desk.
So the data itself was from
the beginning of this year
through about June.
It had 90,000 chat
logs in it that
involved about 67 agents and
about 23,000 unique users.
So it was a pretty
significant sized data set.
And out of that data set, when
we ran the topic modeling API
over it, we came out with
about 100 core topics
that emerged from those chat
log conversations that we then,
clustered down to about 50-ish.
And as we did this, we
began analyzing the output.
What can we learn from this?
And here's two examples
of what we found.
First is we looked at a
month over month analysis
and when we did this, we
found some interesting facts
that our own help desk didn't
really have readily identified
as specific issues that
potentially could be resolved
either A, by improving a process
and therefore, eradicating
the need altogether.
Or using some more
advanced methods,
like being able to
apply Dialogflow
to use some more automated
approaches to responses.
The first was there was a
spike in people requesting
RSA token password resets.
And the spike happened right
around audit busy season.
Well, that's because the
auditors are in the office,
until busy season hits.
And then once busy season hits,
they're out at client sites.
So they haven't used their
RSA token in a month or two,
they forget their password.
They have to get it reset before
they go back out to the client
sites so that they can
VPN in to the network.
Well for us, this
is an opportunity
to automatically do
pre-notifications.
Let's look at all
of our auditors
that haven't used their VPN
in the past four weeks or six
weeks and let's push
them a note with a link
that says, if you need to reset
your password, do it here.
Eradicate the calls altogether.
Another interesting piece of
analysis that we did was we
looked at the median agent
chat word length compared
to the length of the chat, as
well as the number of turns
in each chat-- so how much back
and forth was occurring in each
chart--
along with the total
volume of the chats
that had occurred in
each one of the topics.
And we found a couple
of interesting things.
So one of them was
that if you look
at software installation
as a topic area
and compare it against
conference call information,
you'll see that
answering these chats
took about the same
amount of words.
But look at how
much longer it takes
for the software
installation questions
to be answered properly.
And the difference there is
for the software installation
topics, the agent had to
go and do some research.
They had to go and
get some information.
They had to go and get the right
type of response to give them.
There were no templates.
There was no ready
information available for them
to give to the customers.
When we look at conference
call, it was copy, paste, done.
So same amount of words, but
a lot of increased length.
So conference calls, that
is an immediate low hanging
fruit ready for the application
of Dialogflow to get automated.
I don't need to be answering
that with a human anymore.
It's already templated.
It's ready to go.
On the software
installation side,
I'm looking at this
saying, well, gee,
if I had an Agent
Assist that was saying
I heard them ask about
their time and expense,
here's the information they
need to upgrade their time
and expense.
So opportunities for
improvement were apparent
right from the very
beginning, even
by just doing some
very basic analysis.
But where do we go from here?
So in moving this
forward, the real power
of topic modeling--
as I mentioned--
is that topic modeling
is that foundation.
It's that seed that we can
grow into something else.
And by overlaying a lot of
the application of analytics
over this, we're
able to actually do
some real steady state run
operations in improving the way
that we're serving our
internal customers.
So one of those ways is turning
this into real monitoring.
So if I have my topic modeling
occurring over my customer
channels on an
ongoing basis, then I
can monitor what's spiking.
What are the issues
that are coming up?
What are the issues that I put
a process improvement in place
for because it was a spike?
And can I monitor that
it's being eradicated,
that it's dropping off?
And one of the other areas
is in active programs.
So we all have a lot of
change in our organizations.
We're getting a new tool,
or a new technology,
or a new upgrade, or are
migrating to an operating
system all the time.
And these programs spike the
need for customer service.
The need for the addressment
of questions and issues.
And one of those areas
that we recently had was we
implemented a new T&E system.
And we knew that there was going
to be a spike of information,
a spike of need
for call answering
when we were implementing
this new system.
But what they
didn't readily know
was, what were the very
specific issues people
were having problems with?
How can we improve the
training for the next round
of deployment to make sure
that people don't have
to call about those things?
What are the active
bugs in the system that
are spiking that maybe, just
hadn't been contemplated
in the initial implementation
that we can, again,
prepare to eradicate for in
the next round of deployment?
And so some of the things that
we found were delegate access.
Everyone was having-- there
was a huge spike and people not
being able to identify how to
delegate to other individuals
to handle their T&E.
They were having trouble
uploading their expense receipts
where those were required.
They were also, having
issues in the replication
of their old profile
to the new profile.
So some of these--
like delegate access--
is better FAQs,
better information available.
Better training for the next
rollout-- process improvement.
Some of the others were issues
with the technology that
either needed improvement
or had bugs in them that
needed to be fixed.
But we're able to
monitor them now in a way
that we know something
real is happening
and that it needs
to be addressed.
So with that, please visit
us right outside this door
at the KPMG booth.
We'd love to talk to
you more about this.
And I'm going to hand
it over to Andrea,
from Genesys who's going to
take us through the next piece.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREA FRIIO: Thank
you very much, Traci.
Hello, good morning.
It's a pleasure to be with you.
Probably you noted that
there wasn't my picture
in the presentation for
a very simple reason.
You were probably
expecting it with Andrea,
a nice Italian lady.
The nice Italian lady--
it's me.
Sorry about that.
We start with the bad news.
But let's start
instead with good news.
So first, I want to present
very quickly, my company.
If somebody is not that
familiar with Genesys,
hopefully you saw
our main stage demo.
And if you can
broadcast-- please--
my phone.
So Genesys is a leading solution
provider of customer experience
platforms.
We enjoy this leading
role that is recognized
by our analysts--
so Forrester, we've
been nominated 23 times in
a row in the [INAUDIBLE]
major quadrant.
And we have a similar
appreciation by the analysts,
like Forrester and Ovum.
But especially,
we enjoy the trust
of 11,000 customers
in 100 countries.
And we manage for
them, $25 billion
in interactions per year.
And those are
meaningful interactions.
Those are the
interactions of the top--
if you take the top 100 brands
in the world, 65 of them
are Genesys customers.
So that's what we are.
So I now remove my
act as a salesperson
to become a technical sales.
I want to show you a new channel
that we want to leverage,
thanks to the
partnership with Google.
I want to show you an
application that we built
in combination with Google.
Let's see on the screen.
I want to talk
with Genesys Kate.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: All right,
getting the test version
of Genesys Kate.
KATE: Greetings, this is Kate.
What can I help with?
ANDREA FRIIO:
Search what should I
do if I plan to travel
internationally?
KATE: To prevent an interruption
in credit card access,
it's necessary to set a travel
alert on the credit cards you
plan to use while traveling.
You can set a travel
alert using online banking
by calling the number
on the back of your card
or by talking to GBank automated
agent on your Google Home
device.
ANDREA FRIIO: Perfect--
what we just saw.
This is a new channel.
So I'm a customer of a bank--
GBank.
Actually, I'm at the
bank at Bank of Genesys--
I don't have money,
but I have the bank.
But there was a
customer that wanted
to interact with its own bank.
Imagine yourself for a
second as a consumer,
if you want to talk with your
bank, your insurance-- what
do you do?
You go on the web.
You search for a phone number.
Most of the time when you dial,
they have no clue who they are.
Or if they are really good, they
know thanks to the your number
that you're calling,
who you are.
But they have no idea what
is the intent of your call.
In this particular
case, I just asked
to talk with Genesys
Kate and boom.
Magically, I could ask whatever
question in a natural language
integration.
No flow-- no strict guided
flow in those [INAUDIBLE]..
That's pretty cool.
Let's see something else.
Hey, Google.
Of course, there is
the authentication.
So it's asking to
explore the [INAUDIBLE],,
it's not a good idea.
Talk to Genesys Kate.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK,
let's get the test
version of Genesys Kate.
KATE: Greetings, this is Kate.
What can I help with?
ANDREA FRIIO: What is
exactly travel alert?
KATE: A travel alert allows
the bank to allow transactions
from a foreign country.
This helps to avoid
false fraud alerts.
ANDREA FRIIO: This is
exactly what I need.
Set it up.
KATE: What country
are you going to?
ANDREA FRIIO: I want
to go to France.
KATE: To provide
better service, I'll
just need to get your name and
street address from Google,
is that OK?
ANDREA FRIIO: Yeah.
KATE: Travel alert for
France has been set.
ANDREA FRIIO: Now do you
understand what's happening?
There we get the
confirmation that something
has been happening.
Do you understand
why this new channel?
This is a completely new game.
Immediately, I don't have
to declare [? when. ?]
I can do the
conversation and when
there is information that is
critical, is privacy censored.
Immediately what happens?
Google asks the permission
to pass this information
to the Genesys stack.
So privacy is completely
granted to your customer.
And at the same time, we are
giving an incredible service.
And of course, you noted
probably, also, that we--
you probably noted that
we received an SMS.
Of course because it
was an option that
was [INAUDIBLE] offer,
an action [INAUDIBLE]
this process that these are
top alert for the customer.
In this particular case, we
see Dear Alex, travel alert
for France has been set.
That's great and that was Kate.
Do you know that GBank offers
insurance for trip abroad?
That's fantastic.
Just ask Kate to
schedule a call back.
Not difficult at all, right?
So at this point, let's
invoke one more time, Kate.
I want to talk to Genesys Kate.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK,
let's get the test
version of Genesys Kate.
KATE: Hello, this is Kate.
What can I help with?
ANDREA FRIIO: Call me back.
KATE: To provide
better service, I'll
just need to get your name and
street address from Google,
is that OK?
ANDREA FRIIO: Yeah.
KATE: Calling you right away.
ANDREA FRIIO: Now I ask to
come on the stage, my colleague
Joseph [INAUDIBLE].
So if you can put on
one screen, the agent.
I want to stress what
happened one more time.
We passed the information
of who the customer is.
The platform, after the grant
has been given by Google,
immediately we can call back the
customer without asking a new
question-- which form,
where should I call you--
that has been
passed automatically
thanks to the Google API.
At this point, the caller
will be served by an agent.
So if we have Joe on the screen,
as soon as it's market ready,
I will get the call back
and the dialogue, of course.
I will put the mic on, of
course, because as you know
[INAUDIBLE].
KATE: The person who requested
the callback is on the line.
Press one to speak to a
customer service representative.
Connecting you to a customer
service representative.
Just a moment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The call arrives.
And now at this
point-- of course,
let me off my microphone-- now
the dialogue assistant that you
saw on the screen can start.
So I hope that you has
enjoyed this presentation.
This is definitely the new face
of the customer experience.
Back to you, Daryush.
[APPLAUSE]
DARYUSH LAQAB: Thank you,
Andrea, Ofer, Traci, and Josh.
Appreciate it.
Please, a round of applause
for the sound and video crew.
[APPLAUSE]
So this clock tells me that
I have zero minutes left.
We'd be happy to
take your questions,
but we are getting
kicked out of this room
so we will meet you outside.
We'd be happy to chat with you.
And with that, thanks
so much, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]